i'm off the grid for august but you
would not believe what happened on cnn
while i was gone
i wan i've got to ask you about this
because as we're sitting here waiting
for this you know the the affidavit
redacted affidavit to be released i got
to ask you about this investigation to
these classified documents that kept the
former president kept at former
president trump's mar-a-lago resort
sydney is reporting that biden's white
house counsel's office
at some point defer to the national
archives for determination on how to
handle trump's
protective assertions of privilege or
what have you over these documents
who in the white house knew about this
investigation because the president has
been adamant that he knew nothing he got
no warning about it so those are two
different things so let me just say that
for a second look when it comes to the
investigation the search that we saw uh
recently that you all have reported on
we have been very clear on this the
president was not briefed no one at the
white house was brief we are not briefed
on investigation remember what the
president has said during the campaign
and he has said as president he wanted
to make sure that we restore restore the
independence of
of the department of justice he has been
clear about that especially when it
comes to investigations we do not
comment we do not interfere and we do
not get brief so when it comes to the
investigation
uh itself we are just not going to
comment are you saying that he didn't
know about the actual that there would
there would be a search warrant carried
out because he did have to know about it
about the documents being there because
you have to sign off on the giving the
archives again two different things
right we did not no no we did not know i
again i'm just going to repeat that you
know
you knew that you had to know that the
the that it was there or that they were
missing because he signed off on giving
the archives the authority no
just to be very excuse me no just
i just want to make sure we separate the
two right when it comes to the actual uh
the search when it comes to the comments
uh that
that
the attorney general made recently i
believe it was last week we did not know
about that we learned about that from
your reporting now the letter that's
something totally different what we did
is we deferred we deferred to the
department of justice i'm going to leave
the letter to let the letter speak for
itself that is the national archivist
they've made that decision with the
department of justice again we gave them
uh uh we gave them we deferred that to
the uh nationals who knew about it at
the white house i'm just telling you the
the our the white house i'm not i don't
have specific names of specific the
white house deferred that uh to the
national archivist it's in the letter
it's very clear in the letter people can
uh it's out there you guys have shown
the letter they could folks can take a
look again when it comes to the
investigation when it comes to the
investigation
and the search when it comes to attorney
general making his remarks we do not get
involved we do not
we do not get briefed and we did not
know about that particular about that in
in about that investigation so again we
have said this i know there's a lot of
interest in this but the president has
been very clear we we are he does not
want to politicize the department of
justice he wants to do this very
differently he wants to make sure that
they have the independence when it comes
to investigation again we've been very
very clear about that when it comes to
the letter i refer people to the letter
i refer people to department of justice
the letter is very clear that we defer
that to them